all the fish come out and they start
eating
and all these
[Music]
I'm about to tell you about one of the
worst honeymoons ever what do you think
makes a honeymoon the worst honeymoon
ever fall in shape
can I guess the category yeah is it
heartbreak
injury
or
ruined or missed expectations
that's a big okay well here let me help
you narrow down it it's in Hawaii
so it's them it's their fault no way you
could [__] that up dude I like I love
where you're at
I want you to hold that energy anytime
you say something I feel like I step on
a rake
that's the energy I'm feeling you're on
it but yeah I think it's a little bit of
uh the the second and the third
Heartbreaker how do you [__] up Hawaii
you know but um uh missed what was it
expectation yeah that I can sign up for
a five-star cruise and injury and injury
bed bugs actually you know what it's all
three it's like all three
it is people hurt themselves in Hawaii
all the time yeah so this happened in
Electric Beach in nanakuli you know
Electric Beach Electric Beach would you
recommend it for honeymoons I would
recommend it for snorkeling oh good it's
a wonderful snorkeling spot right but
most people don't own a snorkel why are
you say it like that I almost choked and
drowned there oh that's electrically
because yeah I remember it's beautiful
though because it's right next to uh is
on the west side yeah you're saying
there's a drowning risk well I almost
drowned and died there because they
probably are they all of them Joe threw
up something did you no no it's because
we had a fat breakfast all right and
then I you know like we used to go to
Hawaii like every year multiple times a
year but this time I was like it was a
long break in between so I couldn't wait
to go out and we were just out there you
got a prime rib and I forgot that I was
underwater and I started breathing
the diving
diving I died and I started going and I
was like that's not air and I'm like oh
I've done that I've done that and then I
was like holy [__] and then I went on my
buddies um paddle board and I grabbed it
and I started coughing and I went and
then all the puke came what'd you eat I
had a three pancake sampler it was
literally I love that place it was
[__] my place it was so good it was a
pancake sampler I was eating everybody's
cookie butter bro the cookie butter
pancake butter it was so good you know
breakfast pot I'm talking about yeah
yeah I puke and this is the cool spot
right that's David's itinerary while I'm
coughing [__] spilling out all my
guts all the fish come out and they
start eating
and all these all these people are like
look at all those fish and then they
come and swim all over my barf she like
and I'm just going
I'm like oh all the fish
it's like beautiful and tragic moment
yeah that's a good moment man yeah if my
buddy didn't have his paddle board there
bro I'd be like is it that deep that is
it you can't your foot doesn't touch the
ground because you have to swim out uh
the Electric Beach pretty calm most of
the time because when I went I remember
it was like still and that wasn't like
not me like you have to pass waves or it
just depends on what season right right
but the cool thing is there's it's like
a uh it's called electric because it's
like a power plant there and then they
they push out like they use the water to
cool down [__] and then they push it out
and it's warm and then all the fish and
the life right there there's tons of
fish like it's yeah so you're saying the
thing that happens when you snorkel and
you forget that you're in water you
start pre-coming thing that occurs I I
last time I went snorkeling sometimes
you forget how low you need to be or
like if there's waves sometimes waves
will go into your snorkel and then
you'll inhale and you're like and you'll
freak the [__] out but it's not like you
know you get scared a little bit but
then you're fine but sometimes if you
have a big breakfast then you might
throw up because it's like volunteer
water it's also if you buy a Walmart
snorkel yeah if you get the cheap one
yeah a good one there's a stopper it'll
plug it when it goes in if you use a
snorkel from the Airbnb that you're
saying
you might not be welcome I've literally
experienced never what he's talking
about and also too and also too
um you shouldn't go snorkel by yourself
that's the thing that I've learned
that's true yeah why
because you [__] Anything could
happen anything happened you might step
on a sea urchin you know well here's
what happened uh to this couple that
went on their honeymoon Steve Stephen
fan and Brittany Myers so um yeah Steven
ended up drowning I think possibly in
the same way that you're describing
um bystanders tried to pull him to shore
they try to administer CPR but
wasn't working he died in the hospital
as Britney
returns to the car she finds that
thieves have stolen their phones wallets
clothing and the whole car oh no what
the [__] that might happen that's like
yeah that's the worst honeymoon that
combination imagine literally the
husband dies and then all your shit's
stolen at the same time that's when you
go to that beach there are signs
everywhere saying do not leave valuables
on a car just because of that reason and
like certain areas in Hawaii they have
like signs that are like do not leave
your [__] here because it's a tour spot
right and then people are gonna try
there's a lot of parking lots with just
broken glass everywhere that place that
place has broken glass and everywhere
tourists stand out in the station and
they just don't care
[Laughter]
yeah so in Hawaii Hawaii gets a pretty
high amount of like theft right like
from tourists and like things like that
they know which ones are tourist cars
yeah they are the race cars yeah they
stand out like a [__] yeah
because they all got the [__] the
CarMax
not the sticker on the door so when you
open it and some people leave it on
there and it you just know that like
okay that's a [__] that's what sucks
right yeah that does suck yeah and if
they're all Nissan sentras
yeah man that's such a bad luck dude
that's also like tourists everywhere you
know you go to like Rome or wherever
yeah everyone tells you like keep a low
profile but then Taurus don't listen so
they go everywhere with their expensive
[__] they're nice stuff because they're
on vacation they want to look nice and
then or they keep like their you know
they don't have like that little safety
um like flesh colored fanny pack that
you keep underneath so you get
pickpocketed you know what's crazy too
is that like
so I'm imagining that because they were
out in the water for an extended period
of time because of what happened that
was like probably the moment that
thieves were like oh that's their stuff
that they put aside there's the key and
they did this whole thing while they're
trying to save her husband oh it's so
[__] up man but yeah there's a
GoFundMe right now if you guys want to
support the Myers fan GoFundMe uh side
note so I saw this original article on
neck shark and there was a top comment
that I thought was so neck shark
um some guy said oh it's because it was
an Asian guy with a white wife
that's practically a Target on your back
what
there's so many he says that there's so
many couples there that are it's
actually the
that's the top comment that means people
like no it's like
Hawaii's the top state of interracial
marriages and make like mix like peoples
yeah there's there's a whole name for
like have why half Hawaiian whatever
it's called Hapa yeah and then I was
like why did this guy believe that and
then I looked at his profile and it was
just all Voltron
but yeah if you go swim though like
number one will always swim with the
buddy yeah for that reason water I think
they were with the they're not by
themselves or like they might have been
with the tour group or something and
then they just I think he just they
couldn't
keep them up or whatever I read this
whole thing it was [__] up but he
wasn't swimming with the buddy because
if you are
like they would recognize immediately
when they go unconscious you might have
been with the group but he probably went
off by himself but you always need to
swim with the Buddy people underestimate
like swimming out in those waters you
know like yeah or just in general like
if you're not a very good swimmer and
you try to do stuff like that like you
can get in some serious trouble because
there's also a thing called uh shallow
water blackout which happens a lot like
people don't know but you can die in
three feet of water because especially
people that don't like regularly swim
yeah all of a sudden they're doing
things where it's like
looking at crabs and [__] they're all
safe this is three water uh three feet
of water you know and then but then that
type of hyperventilation and controlling
your breath you're not used to it and
then like all of a sudden you just
[__] pass out and you just die in
three if you don't think about that yeah
so it's like it's not really the depth
of water that's lethal it's how often
you do what you're about to do yeah oh I
never thought about that yeah sometimes
I just look at people like they're so
weak
Honestly though some people really are
like some people really are like they're
not physically fit at all to do
activities they do these activities and
then they're just like not ready for it
we went kayaking and Lanikai all the way
to this like Island that was like and as
we're doing it we're like this is a
[__] mistake
it's much farther than it looks oh yeah
it was so fun
I went with another couple and we were
just fighting with our ladies the whole
time
not a real vacation
dude there's a [__] they're yelling
at nothing you know but it's like we're
we feel comfortable kayaking like so we
we feel pretty comfortable with all that
but then there
they're kind of scared right because we
have to like dock we have to time the
wave to get to the island are you with
your lady on one and or yeah two dudes
online we're no we're out me and her and
yeah yeah couples on one side screaming
at you I would love to be the dudes
online shake their kayak yeah but we
were cruising we're going we're going
and then they're like I'm tired and then
we're just doing all the paddling which
is fine not a big deal but you see all
these people we saw these like these
tourists come in and they were kayaking
and they were in like civilian clothes
right yeah they're not experts oh they
suck ass let me tell you they weren't
experts because they have to time their
kayak to get out of the shore and that's
it's the hardest part and they're
getting destroyed by waves right and
they were getting hit in the face with a
kayak like just getting [__] up and
they thought it was gonna be like oh
it's gonna be fun we're just gonna like
it's a [__] British Park Pond but
it's like you have to remember like
there's jellyfish out here there's
[__] like this is this is the wild
you can't be [__] around like you've
got to be kind of careful when you do
that you gotta respect the nature yeah
bro so it's kind of like personal
responsibility too I'm not saying for
this guy no for sure yeah General like
because you always hear locals say like
oh all the tourists get [__] up over
here and we tell them but they don't
listen they want to do their own thing
that is true yeah a lot of my local
friends have a story of multiple times
they saved lives of tourists from either
drowning or just like being caught in
Riptides or just like weird like it's
like there's just too many people that
get [__] up yeah a lot of people don't
know what they're getting take some
swimming lessons you know
[Music]
thank you